voluntarios y funcionarios de la
alcaldía de la paz se unen por una buena
causa convertir un predio de más de 30
hectáreas en las afueras de la capital
en un santuario de árboles y en los
pulmones de la ciudad una proyección a
futuro para el país andino queremos que
cuando se abra este sea un bosque que
pueda ser aprovechado por todas las
familias paseñas y no para señas que
vivan en la paz este pasado viernes en
el día del árbol comenzaron a plantar
unos 300 plantines donde antes se
votaban los desechos y en total serán
6.000 árboles los que harán parte de
este proyecto el alcalde de la paz iván
arias fue el primero en sembrar con la
plantación de arbolitos empezamos el
camino para convertir el ex relleno
sanitario de mayasa en un bosquecillo
con seis mil árboles la ciudad necesita
más áreas verdes al menos 12 hectáreas
serán forestadas con unas 9 especies de
árboles y arbustos característicos de
los valles andinos secos que tienen
importantes aportes ambientales y que
requieren de poca agua se prevé que en
marzo de 2022 se haya completado la
forestación y que en 2031 el sueño de
tener un bosque se haga realidad